I'm losing
[music]
ani
ban It's
beautiful to enter
Now, re It's a
great fight, human being, the
bottom of the seashore
Chile at Marugran My colleague in solidarity,
well, if it becomes a power that surpasses even Satan and the four generals,
then I'll have to deal with it with all my heart.
If you don't have it, command your troops quickly. The
power of the 8th place of the government, which has grown for the first time since coming here, isn't half-hearted power.
I can't do it, but I'm hoping
c 0 I'm
up to Kinniku Ataru I do
n't think I'm going to tease you right
[Music]
It's easier to do things on equal terms
To not kill the enemy Hehe It's
funny
After the cherry  I don't know if I'll be lame if I declare other rare blankets without killing Yoshimaru, but
I'm going to slaughter them.